here's how adding free products or
services to the things you sell can
actually backfire they found this out in
a study of a beauty store that sold
makeup because what happens is they gave
them a pearl necklace as a gift for
making a purchase of a box of makeup and
people didn't even think the pro
necklace was real so whenever you add a
free bonus or free thing that someone
can get when they make a purchase with
you the person will actually perceived
that thing as less valuable because they
assume it must not be good because
you're giving it away for free and so
the way to do it is you add two things
to your persuasion number one is you
show what it actually retails for that
way they know that this thing has value
second rather than saying free you say
at no cost to you or complementary and
by doing that they'll say here's the
retail cost and it comes at no cost to
you or here's the retail cost and it's
complementary with the purchase rather
than here's a free thing it's probably
junk because it's free and that's why
I'm giving it to you and by doing that
you can increase the total value of the
packages that you're selling